if you know the right people who know
the right routes there's a way round the
government checkpoints our guide took us
to the parts of Homs controlled by
anti-government forces Spanish
it's a place where the refuse is no
longer collected we're a spare bedroom
becomes a hospital ward this man says he
was shot by government troops a place
where an office is a clinic a generator
for power and an x-ray machine smuggled
in helps the treatment of another sniper
victim lambs have arrived or camina
camina this man is a carpenter turned
volunteer nurse last week he was hit by
a sniper as he tried to drag this
wounded man to safety men queue to give
blood a lot has been spilled
[Music]
thirty-three-year-old hier noch juan was
brought in while we were there his body
showed signs of torture two weeks
previously he'd been caught by
government troops while carrying a
pistol now his family prepared to bury
him the coughing carried in circles the
signal that he was in their eyes a
martyr moving around town we cross
through governmental districts to get to
bab am there the anti-government forces
don't want to be filmed and don't want
Outsiders knowing they're building
defensive positions we can go this far
no further the open space by the stadium
a killing ground for snipers in this
tower block the route we came into baba
Mia is now blocked the government forces
have put up what the opposition call
flying checkpoints we're now waiting to
find a different route out there is a
way back in all we've switched cars five
times
another opposition bunker in charge Omar
sham see his ID says he was a lieutenant
in the army before defecting if the army
comes to raid any area we take strategic
positions we have lights and medium
weapons we only defend the
demonstrations they look ill-equipped to
go on the offensive the commander says
he's got about 30 men all of them
trained soldiers who've defected to
defend this district of Homs but if the
Syrian army comes in force these weapons
will be no match
the opposition gave us this video they
say this was the battle for homes before
the Arab League agreement forced the
heavy armor back without the monitors it
may return this family has had enough
we're leaving the bullets behind he says
we're going to Damascus five families
have left this street says this woman
Syria is slowly splitting there are many
caught in the middle who don't want to
have to be on either side Tim Marshall
Sky News Homs